don't aim to be the best
aim to be the only we're on a grand
journey of trying to open up the
possibilities to allow that every person
born and yet unborn would have a chance
to develop their genius to become the
only and to share that with us as a
benefit you're always on that journey of
trying to figure out what what it is
about yourself that is special and
unique it will take most of your life to
arrive there the proper way is the start
is to master something
and in that Mastery that becomes a
platform that you begin to kind of move
towards discovering passion is a product
of action exactly it's not the other way
around exactly waiting around until
you're struck with what you're
passionate about as a as a precursor to
action is like a protracted period of
confusion exactly